HERE WITH ME NOW CNN'S SENIOR
LEGAL ANALYST AND FORMER FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR ELLIE HONING.
AGAIN, WHAT WE KNOW AND WHAT WE
DON'T KNOW, BOTH VERY IMPORTANT.
>> LET ME START WITH THE EASY
PART OF THIS QUIZ, WHAT WE DO
KNOW, JOHN, THREE THINGS THAT WE
KNOW FOR SURE, PROSECUTORS FIRST
OF ALL ESTABLISHED PROBABLE
CAUSE THAT A SPECIFIC FEDERAL
CRIME WAS COMMITTED, THEY
ESTABLISHED THAT IT WAS LIKELY
THAT THEY WOULD FIND EVIDENCE AT
THE LOCATION AT MAR-A-LAGO AND
WE KNOW THAT THAT WAS APPROVED
BY A FEDERAL JUDGE.
OKAY.
WE HAVE THAT IN PLACE.
THE REST OF THIS IS UNANSWERED.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST QUESTIONS,
WHAT EVIDENCE DID PROSECUTORS
USE TO ESTABLISH THAT PROBABLE
CAUSE?
NOW, THE WAY DO YOU THIS AS A
PROSECUTOR IS YOU HAVE TO WRITE
OUT WHAT WE CALL AN AFFIDAVIT IN
SUPPORT OF A SEARCH WARRANT.
THESE DOCUMENTS CAN BE DOZENS OF
PAGES, THIS IS ACTUALLY THE ONE
FROM THE MICHAEL COHEN CASE
WHICH WAS OVER 200 PAGES LONG.
THIS IS THE ROSETTA STONE, THIS
WILL TELL US EVERYTHING WE NEED
TO KNOW.
WHO HAS IT?
PROSECUTORS HAVE IT, THE JUDGE
HAS IT BUT IT IS UNDER SEAL NOT
AVAILABLE TO US IN THE PUBLIC.
DONALD TRUMP DOES NOT HAVE THIS
DOCUMENT IN HIS POSSESSION.
HE WON'T GET IT UNLESS THERE
EVER COMES A DAY WHEN HE IS
CHARGED.
>> BUT HE DOES HAVE SOMETHING.
>> EXACTLY.
HE DOES HAVE WHAT WE CALL A
SEARCH WARRANT.
DOES HE HAVE A COPY?
YES.
CAN HE RELEASE IT?
HOWEVER, THERE'S FAIRLY LIMITED
INFORMATION IN THIS DOCUMENT.
IT'S ONE PAGE.
THIS IS IT, THIS IS A SAMPLE OF
IT.
IT TELLS YOU WHERE IS TO BE
SEARCHED, MAR-A-LAGO, WHAT ARE
THEY LOOKING FOR.
IT WILL SAY THINGS LIKE
DOCUMENTS, PAPERS, COMPUTERS, IT
WON'T GUESS INTO SPECIFICITY
USUALLY, WHO IS THE JUDGE AND
WHEN DOES THE FBI HAVE TO
CONDUCT THE SEARCH WARRANT BY.
HOWEVER, SOMETIMES THERE IS AN
ATTACHMENT TO THIS AND THAT CAN
TELL YOU HERE ARE THE CRIMES
THAT PROSECUTORS ALLEGE MAY HAVE
BEEN COMMITTED.
SO DONALD TRUMP DOES HAVE THAT
DOCUMENT, BUT IT WILL NOT GIVE
CHAPTER AND VERSE.
ANOTHER IMPORTANT DOCUMENT THAT
DONALD TRUMP HAS WILL ANSWER THE
QUESTION OF WHAT DID THE FBI
TAKE FROM MAR-A-LAGO.
NOW, THIS IS CALLED A RETURN.
IT'S BASICALLY AN INVOICE.
IT'S A RECEIPT.
THE FBI WILL SAY, HERE IS WHAT
WE TOOK OUT OF YOUR PROPERTY.
BUT, AGAIN, THERE IS A LEVEL OF
GENERALITIES TO THAT.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO DETAIL
EVERY PIECE OF PAPER.
IT WILL MORE LIKELY SAY
SOMETHING LIKE 12 BOXES, X
NUMBER OF LAPTOPS, THAT KIND OF
THING, BUT DONALD TRUMP THAT IS
THAT, HE CAN RELEASE THAT, TOO.
>> AGAIN, IF IT'S INNOCUOUS,
THOUGH, THE WARRANT ITSELF, WHY
WOULDN'T HE RELEASE IT?
IS IT A POSSIBILITY OF AN
ATTACHMENT THAT OUTLINES THE
CRIMES?
>> THAT COULD WELL BE.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING.
IF THERE IS THAT ATTACHMENT AND
IT FAIRLY FREQUENTLY DOES HAVE
AN ATTACHMENT TO IT, IT WOULD
SAY TYPICALLY WE BELIEVE THAT
HERE IS THE CRIMES WE
ESTABLISHED PROBABLE CAUSE,
TRUMP MAY NOT WANT THAT OUT
THERE.
>> AND, AGAIN, HE COULD RELEASE
THAT IF HE WANTED TO.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> FOR ALL THE CALLS FORMER RICK
GARLAND TO COME OUT AND SAY
SOMETHING RIGHT NOW, TRUMP COULD
DO THAT.
>> THEY BOTH HAVE INFORMATION.
TRUMP COULD RELEASE THAT.
>> WHAT DOCUMENTS EXACTLY WERE
STILL AT MAR-A-LAGO AT THE
MOMENT THE SEARCH WARRANT WAS
EXECUTED?
WE KNOW THAT EARLIER THIS YEAR
THERE WERE 15 BOXES OF DOCUMENTS
DELIVERED FROM MAR-A-LAGO TO THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES.
DOJ THEN OBTAINED THOSE SAME 15
BOXES FROM THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES.
NOW, DOJ AS OUR NEW REPORTING
HAS SHOWN STARTED TO GROW
SUSPICIOUS AND LEARNED THERE
WERE OTHER DOCUMENTS THERE AND
STARTED TO GROW DISTRUSTFUL OF
THE WAY THEY WERE BEING HANDLED.
THEY WENT IN, DID THE SEARCH
WARRANT AND OUR REPORTING NOW IS
THAT DOJ HAS GRABBED ABOUT 12
MORE BOXES FROM MAR-A-LAGO.
WHAT'S IN THERE, WE WILL FIND
OUT.
AND THEN THERE IS THE QUESTION
OF WHY DID DOJ EXACTLY USE A
SEARCH WARRANT INSTEAD OF LESS
INTRUSIVE MEANS.
THERE IS A AN INTERESTING
HISTORY HERE.
BACK IN JUNE THERE ARE MEETINGS
THAT WERE REPORTED FOR US THAT
INVESTIGATORS MET WITH TRUMP'S
TEAM AT MAR-A-LAGO, WERE SHOWN
THERE WERE OTHER BOXES OF
DOCUMENTS IN THE BASEMENT AND
THE INVESTIGATORS CAME BACK AND
SAID THROW A PADLOCK ON THAT,
SAVE THEM FOR US.
SO WHY WERE INVESTIGATORS OKAY
WITH THAT?
WHY WERE THEY OKAY WITH THOSE
DOCUMENTS STAYING AT MAR-A-LAGO
FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS UNTIL
AUGUST 8th, UNTIL TWO DAYS AGO
WHEN THEY EXECUTED THE SEARCH
WARRANT IS THIS THAT'S AN
INTRUSIVE MEANS AND I THINK
ULTIMATELY DOJ WILL HAVE TO
JUSTIFY IT.
>> THAT'S ONE OF THE UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS HERE.
THE ANSWER TO THAT IF IT EXISTS
MIGHT EXPLAIN SOMETHING.
ONE OF THE THINGS THROWN OUT BY
TRUMP ALLIES IS THIS INFORMATION
WAS DECLASSIFIED ANY WAY.
>> PAM BROWN HAS NEW REPORTING
THAT THAT MAY BE ONE OF THE
DEFENSES.
WE MAY SEE A DEFENSE THAT TRUMP
DID DECLASSIFY THEM.
YOU HAVE TO DO IT WHILE YOU ARE
PRESIDENT, YOU CAN'T DO IT MANY
MONTHS LATER.
THE QUESTION IS DID HE
DECLASSIFY.
THERE IS NO SPECIFIC FORM YOU
HAVE TO FILL OUT TO DECLASSIFY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BROAD
AUTHORITY OVER THAT.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT IS THE
EVIDENCE SHOW?
IS THERE ACTUALLY PROOF THAT HE
DECLASSIFIED?
WATCH FOR THAT, THAT COULD BE A
BATTLE COMING UP.
>> EVERYONE CALLING FOR MERRICK
GARLAND TO COME FORWARD WITH
INFORMATION.
CAN DOJ DO SO?
>> HE CAN.
HE IS ALLOWED TO.
I WOULD LOVE FOR HIM TO TELL US
WHAT'S GOING ON, BUT I DO NOT
BELIEVE HE WILL GIVEN HIS
HISTORY AND GIVEN A REALLY
IMPORTANT PROSECUTORIAL
PRINCIPLE, YOU DO NOT TALK ABOUT
PENDING INVESTIGATIONS.
PART OF THAT IS STRATEGIC.
BILL BELICHICK DOESN'T WALK HIS
PLAYBOOK ACROSS TO THE OTHER
SIDELINE TO SAY HERE IS WHAT
WE'RE DOING.
>> HE TAPES PRACTICES,
ALLEGEDLY.
>> NOT THE BEST EXAMPLE.
YOU WANT TO MAINTAIN OF THE
SECRECY OF YOUR INVESTIGATION
YOU DON'T WANT TO TELL THE OTHER
TEAM WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
PART OF THAT IS THE PRINCIPLE TO
PROTECT THE RIGHTS AND
REPUTATION OF WHOEVER MAY BE
UNDER INVESTIGATION.
GENERALLY SPEAKING THE PERSON
BEING INVESTIGATED DOESN'T WANT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL COMING OUT
AND SAYING WE BELIEVE THIS
PERSON MAY HAVE COMMITTED A
CRIME.
>> THE PROXIMITY OF THE MIDTERMS
HERE, ARE THEY PLAYING INTO
THIS?
>> MIDTERMS ARE NOW EXACTLY 90
DAYS AWAY AND THAT MATTERS
BECAUSE THERE IS A LONG-STANDING
DOJ POLICY YOU DON'T TAKE AN
OVERINVESTIGATIVE STEP LIKE A
SEARCH WARRANT THAT MAY BE
POLITICALLY SENSITIVE WITHIN 90
DAYS OF THE MIDTERM SO THEY DID
THAT SEARCH 92 DAYS BEFORE,
MAYBE COINCIDENCE, MAYBE BECAUSE
THEY WERE TRYING TO STAY OUT OF
THAT --
>> DOES IT MATTER THAT DONALD
TRUMP IS NOT RUNNING IN THE
MIDTERMS.
>> THERE IS A WAY TO TECHNICALLY
CONSTRUE THAT MEMO, BUT WHO
LOOMS LARGE OVER THESE
ELECTIONS?
>> VERY HELPFUL AS ALWAYS.
THANK YOU.